all right so now turning now to the
beloved american craft tradition
quilting now we all know technology and
machines that make things faster but
what does that mean for creations that
are made with love and stitched by hand
on a swing through mississippi jan
crawford visited a group of quilters who
are worried their future is at risk
because of the slow pace of their art
each stitch is a connection a thread to
the past every quilt has a story
here in the heart of the delta tutwiler
mississippi considered by many a
birthplace of the blues cotton country
there are a lot of stories to tell some
of those stories are told in quilts
part of it it has a lot to do with our
history as well
you know back in slavery times equipped
with hidden messages in them like a a
map to the north and that's why you call
that the northern it is really it is
that's kind of a nod to
the ancestors right exactly but there
aren't that many quilters anymore to
tell those stories is this a thing of
the past
it is
we're losing it we're losing it
because
we don't have people that want to do it
you know you got to have patient
time and the love for it
in rural communities quilting was once
for necessity women quilted
to keep their families warm melanie
powell is the executive director of the
tuttweiler community education center so
some women would just pick up the cotton
that was left over in the fields and use
it to stuff and to make the batting for
the quilts that they made
more than 30 years ago the community
center started selling the homemade
quilts to the public first told in a
1990 story on 60 minutes with that
particular program women have been given
the opportunity
to make their own money by quilting
their items at home
they bring them into the center and it's
our responsibility to sell those items
the tudweiler quilts can cost up to 400
the quilters get eighty percent of the
sale price the rest goes to the
community center for materials mary
mackey coordinates the center's quilting
program that was one way that
we could sit at home
make money take care of our kids and
support our family how many hours will
be involved from start to finish
sometimes it'd be
two by two months before i'm going to
finish it up and the patterns are as
varied as their imaginations
[Music]
there are now programmable quilting
machines allowing almost anybody to
create beautiful and nearly perfect
quilts but the quilters of tuttweiler
prefer the old-fashioned needle and
thread
it's something special about handmade
products it's a lot of loveliness and
it's a lot of imperfection
in this and there's beauty in those
imperfections it's absolutely beauty
some of these women have been quilting
most of their lives they lament that the
younger generation doesn't seem
interested they have other things
internet
cell phones
you see where the lady
quitting
she's not wearing a therma at all you
know and you got a lot of pin sticks in
your finger and you
young people don't want all this
the pain that hurts the pain
the imperfections the pain quilts are
like the delta these women call home and
like life beautiful
for cbs morning's jan crawford
tuttweiler mississippi wow
wow look at that last one beautiful it's
gorgeous
makes me wish that we could do something
like that i mean it it really does seem
to be a lost art yeah you got to figure
out a way to teach us how to do that
yeah i'm pretty good at getting under a
quilt yeah yeah
that's about it with something on tv me
too
i can't say very good at that